i've just i've been so
so [ __ ] sad like
i
like to the point where i just i didn't
want to feel it anymore i've had three
different like
suicide attempts
i've been slitting my wrists for 10
years
i just don't want to feel that way
anymore so that's why when i tell my
story
i don't i don't want to bring up how
i've od
10
13 times i don't
i don't want to get into the depths of
me hanging myself or trying to drown
myself because um i think the most
important part is to just
giving background of where i came from
so that you can see why i became a drug
addict and then on top of that like
seeing that people do make it out
like it's not like that forever and um
i'm just glad that i
made it out when i did and realized that
i can be happy and i deserve to be happy
because all that [ __ ] that happens is
just
the outcome of actions and if i make
better actions now then i know the
outcome's going to be
far better
than how it used to be and i have faith
in that
all right izzy
izzy where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um i grew up in salem
massachusetts
and
i ended up in rhode island so most of my
childhood was on the east coast
and how was your family
um
it was a weird setup
my mom
and dad my dad met my mom in the strip
club before i was born like 1997
and
i don't know my mom says that like i was
wanted but she was with him for a few
months and he ended up leaving
around when i got was born
because my mom stabbed him
and
he just i don't know i talked to him
about it and he told me that he was just
gonna let me like let god work it out
and i'll eventually find him so i grew
up with my mom
she was a sex worker
for most of my childhood
uh
it was like a
weird situation she was very
evil
i would say um
i was getting abused since i was like
six years old physically
my first grade picture i had a black eye
and she covered it with makeup that day
i just got in trouble for a lot of
things that like i didn't understand
um
i don't know how it
conspired but uh i
i was a very sexual kid
i i can't recall i don't think anything
ever happened to me sexually
but i started having a porn addiction at
around six or seven years old
i i was
obsessed with like
woman
specifically
i don't know if it was the hyper
femininity from my mom
or like because she was always like the
sexy mom
i don't know what it was
but
i i remember in kindergarten i had a
girlfriend
and we used to like make out in the
bathroom stalls and like get naked
uh
i just i've always just been like
addicted to woman
and
sex as a whole
around like
12 was when i started webcaming
and
it was just like weird for me because it
wasn't something that my mom ever talked
to me about
uh
i just
when i was getting like phones and stuff
i would be looking up pictures of naked
girls
like
masturbating all the time on webcam
until they would like kick me off
servers
so i was just always really comfortable
with sex in myself
um
i
remember when i was 12 my mom ended up
like
getting engaged to this
rich dude
and we moved in with him to rhode island
that's when that's when i ended up
leaving salem and that kind of like
changed my whole entire life
i wasn't around my friends anymore
i was
sexually super confused
i liked guys and girls
but i still had that like infatuation
with women
and i didn't really know how to express
that because as i got older
i was bullied a lot so i really wasn't
able to have that connection like i was
when i was younger and we don't really
think about like
judging kids and people
um
i was i was self-harming
when i moved and that's when i started
getting really alternative and into like
metal music
i did want friends
but everything i did
made me very unapproachable
so i kind of like singled myself out and
didn't really understand why people
didn't like me because i
i love people
i
i fall in love with like everybody i
meet
and
i
started smoking weed and drinking
when i got there
i
i used to like drink cough syrup out of
like the cabinet when i was younger but
i wasn't like always looking for that
high because i was getting the feelings
i needed from like
the sex kind of stuff
anything that just makes me feel super
in love just
i love that [ __ ]
and
i
i was running away a lot
when i when i was in rhode island i
remember my mom was in jail for a little
bit so i was alone with this dude uh i
don't recall him ever being like creepy
or weird with me but it was just awkward
because i didn't really know him and she
just had me move in with this dude into
a whole other state so
i was just always you know finding older
friends that i could go hang out with um
when my mom got back from jail that's
when it the abuse started happening
again i mean constant physical fights
uh
the the police knew me so well just as
the girl that was always getting in
fights with her mom
she quit doing sex work around a little
bit after we moved to rhode island but i
do remember her still going to the clubs
and stuff
uh
i always viewed her little fiance dude
as a trick i'm now that i'm a little bit
older i mean
i don't really see what there was to
love about that whole situation i
remember one time he
like how they broke up was he got really
drunk and was standing over my bed naked
and
i don't recall anything happening but
she just didn't
need that in my life so he ended up like
kicking us out
and all this [ __ ]
it was just like
a mess
um
at around 13 14 was when i started
running away a lot
uh
i
i had gotten in contact with my dad
but
he was still far away
uh he
he definitely loved me
it was like he was waiting for me to
eventually like reach out she found him
on facebook and said your daughter wants
to talk to her so he was like in my life
kind of
but he was in colorado at the time
so i remember on one of my little
runaway stints now when i ran away
since i'm like from small cities i've
always gravitated towards big ones
because i'm like i can't do anything out
here there's nothing to [ __ ] do
and um and everybody knows me at this
point like i'm i'm normally like the one
mixed girl i'm i'm iranian and puerto
rican
so like i was always like the one brown
kid in most situations
and kind of hard to forget
so i would always i remember like taking
buses to
providence to take
a train to boston to take another train
to new york and
yeah i would just disappear i would let
my mom know hey i'm leaving throw my sim
card out and i would just be out on the
streets and i'd just come back when i
came back
each time was a little different
um
i used my body to get around places uh
i'd lie about my age but people knew who
i like
when you're 14 you can't really pass for
much than 14 i didn't
i got a boob job right now like i was
flat chested i had a baby face
so
i mean but it didn't really bother me my
mom supported me like that
like just being hot so i figured as long
as i looked good you know i was the one
girl on the streets i'd have my
straightener my makeup
and like a bunch of hoochie mama outfits
and um
and it worked i
i definitely
i was okay i was on the streets a lot
but i'd always find a way to get into
someone's apartment and have a place to
stay for a little bit and until i got
tired of the runs and then i just come
back home and
i don't know my mom stopped
really worrying about me
i was
whenever there was like a report for me
missing it wasn't because she reported
it she knew i'd always end up back home
and there was nothing she could really
do about it
um
and then
when i was
like 15
just turning 16 i met this dude who was
like 10 years old older than me
and i was in love with him
i ended up moving into his apartment
pretty quickly
his friends knew how old i was i used to
brag i'd be like i just turned 16 like
that was like
any better
being with somebody who was like 25 26
so
he took care of me
and um
like i said i'm a lover
and
my idea of loving someone is being able
to provide for them and i wasn't really
able to do that at the time i had [ __ ]
up school
i never went and
so it was hard for me to get jobs and
such
so
i started posting
ads i mean on the streets it was
different when you're just like meeting
up with people but this is when i
started putting myself out there
i was doing
pet play
where you
to my knowledge when i was a like teen i
got into it because it was cute
you wear little cat ears and like butt
plugs and you pretend you're a cat now
i'm like a big anime fan
so
i just i didn't see the problem with
this and i didn't understand the
underlying kink behind it
um at this time i was drinking and i was
doing like smoking weed
but i really wasn't into like
heavy heavy drugs like that
and
he didn't know what i was doing i would
just say i'm gone and come back the next
day with money and i wouldn't really
like i would
i honestly don't even remember my
excuses for it i just i had money and
i don't know
um
now when i started
my first thing with meth was when i was
seeing this dude
i he was very rich and
i i knew his name
because he was like kind of a
high-profile client as they would call
them
and
i remember walking into this big-ass
house and i felt safe because i'm like
well somebody with a name and with that
has this kind of publicity like
there they can't really afford to
[ __ ] me over and i wasn't really ever
scared of people i mean as long as i got
paid and i didn't get like
physically hurt it really didn't bother
me what was going on
and
i remember this cute dog
and
i was like petting him while we were
talking for a little bit and i was
getting dressed
and then he told me that he likes to use
meth to have fun and i was like okay
whatever
um
i
guess i've just always been adventurous
i was always one of those kids that
would say yeah i'll try any drug
so i just did it
and
he put me in this little cage
and
that was normal in a pet place scenario
you know like cage bowl
things being on four knees crawling
around
but then he had his
dog go in the cage with me
and i spent
i remember i went in on a tuesday
and
he would just
keep giving me meth and
having his dog rape me
um
and like
it's not something i really enjoyed but
when you're spun the [ __ ] out
you don't really
i was just i was grateful for it you
know i was grateful for the math because
whatever mind state i was in or what i
was feeling
was probably better than being sober
so
he let me out after like a little over
three four days
i remember he said i work on the
weekends
and he gave me like
you know like four grand or something
and i didn't even want to put up a fight
i mean i was glad i was out looking back
i should have demanded way more money i
should have
done something i should i could have
taken the money and i could have still
reported him but like i did not give a
[ __ ] i just wanted to leave
um
and then that's when i remember going
back to that boyfriend's house and
he caught me he like looked through my
phone i remember i brought back coffee
and i kissed him and i was like hey i'm
back
and um
i left to go shower and he looked
through my phone and he saw all my ads
and
that's when he told my mom and he told
like the whole town that i was that i
was a hooker
um
it was weird
i ended up going back to my mom's house
and she had the pictures of the ads and
she didn't even
say anything this is the woman who beat
my ass for
not cleaning my room
beat my ass for not coming home on time
beat my ass for
anything me having an attitude and um
she's kind of like shrugged she's like
are you okay
i was like yeah i'm good
so like there was this thing in my head
that like it was okay it was okay i was
a sex worker
and
part of me maybe even felt like you know
i followed in mom's footsteps
maybe that's why she doesn't you know
how the [ __ ] can you blame me
i saw how she provided for me so that's
how i provided for myself and people
that i loved
um
from there my childhood gets a little
splotchy
i i ran away a million times after that
living in
crack houses and
i did eventually run back run away to my
dad's place in colorado
he tried to get me into school over
there
but
this is the man i've been dying to live
with him i've been wanting to be in his
life so bad and i finally get the
[ __ ] opportunity too and uh
and i ran away
because he felt more like a friend and
not a father i never even had a father
to know like
how one is supposed to be he was
supportive
he didn't care about like anything going
on like what i did he just was glad i
was in his life and i ran away to go be
on the streets
um no no i just
i remember skipping school and him
riding his bike around my school and
finding me like
smoking [ __ ]
k2 that we got from the gas station
um
just
liked being high
um
and yeah sex work just was the thing i
did i didn't even
it i don't really
i don't know where the correlation
between me being a sex worker and the um
and my sex addiction really connects
because um sex work always felt like a
job and it wasn't really something i
enjoyed like that
but i didn't really have a problem with
it either
drugs helped that a lot
i got into
i got into meth pretty heavy in my teen
years because it's just
i correlated safety
i felt safe
um
you could do anything to me and i was
good
so
that was like my childhood i guess
lots of drugs and sex and street life
the drug use continued
yeah
i was never really physically addicted
to anything i mean i remember when i was
younger they would say like don't try
meth even once like you get addicted and
they'd show these horrible pictures of
people like after a few months of use
um
but i would go on like
binges and then i would just drop it i
mean it was really hard for a teenager
to get meth
as like
i don't know maybe it was just where i
was looking but i kind of just did
whatever but i was never physically
addicted to anything but i did always
need to be [ __ ] up
um
when i was 18 that's when i got into
porn
and they flew me out to florida
and
i
i had a rule i would never get [ __ ] up
on camera because i didn't want people
to see me like that i know how
embarrassing i am when i'm [ __ ] up so
i would just do
drugs and alcohol
any time between i mean i was casually
doing
heroin dropping it
doing something else did a lot of coke
um
molly i [ __ ] loved molly i would do
that [ __ ] for weeks until i would get
clean off of it and then i'd have like
such bad headaches i would [ __ ] black
out every once in a while i don't know
it's
acid
nothing major though
um
yeah
so throughout
porn and being with sugar daddies all
the time i uh
i always
i was always [ __ ] up
um that's just how i lived my life sex
drugs and rock and roll and i
and i owned that [ __ ] i always knew i
had a problem using
um
and when i started doing meth and heroin
i
it was it was regular i did fentanyl
here and
there but it was never really like that
[ __ ] bad like i would actually do it
once and i'd be like okay that was cool
and then i would like kind of forget
about it it wasn't something i always
seeked out
because i liked uppers i didn't like
feeling down and in my feelings and
depressed
um
my fentanyl addiction started about two
years ago
when uh
i met this dude
and
i the moment that i saw him i was like
yeah i definitely want to be with him
he's all tatted up and
i i always like was with
like
emo boys alternative boys i never really
since i've been
before la i wasn't really around gang
bangers except for when i was in the
streets in new york and um
and i [ __ ] hated them they were so
mean
and uh i didn't really
like
the [ __ ] that they made me do because i
was like you know it was always just
money based [ __ ] if i wasn't helping
make money then it just wasn't
wasn't it
and i
i wanted to be in love so i remember
meeting this dude
and he hit me up
after he saw me at a party
he said when can i be with he said when
can i see you and i said i'm yours
whenever you want me
and
we hooked up the next day he told me
when we were [ __ ] i want to
have a baby with you i want you to i
like i want you to be my wife and all
this [ __ ] and i said bet
i got you
he uh he smoked 30s
and he always used to tell me like these
are the real ones we don't do fake [ __ ]
and i was like okay whatever
so um
i don't know we were
we were smoking them and
i didn't really get the physical
addiction too bad too bad
and then he got
locked up
and i lost my [ __ ]
i
i need to be with the person that i'm
with
like
all the time
i
i need to be able to see you like
whenever
so
him being gone kind of just broke me
down and i started i just wanted to be
closer to him some way somehow so i just
started doing what he did and smoking
30s all the time now i didn't have his
plug
i didn't want to ask him for it so i was
doing fake pills and i like them more
i like those way more um
i i got way higher
and um
yeah i ended up leaving and going to
this was when i was in cali and i ended
up eventually leaving in the middle of
him being in jail
and going to vegas and then that's when
i started getting like really good
[ __ ]
fentanyl pills
and
it was from there i mean i knew i was
addicted i'd be getting sick when i
wasn't on them but
i i couldn't stop and this was the first
time i was physically addicted to
something i didn't understand like
withdrawals
i didn't
and then
yeah when he got out
i had tried going to treatment last year
and i didn't last more than like five
days
um i was like oh man if i get high now
i can just stop
after a day and you know
i've tried to get clean repeatedly over
the past couple years
but i just i couldn't do it i always
replaced it with some sort of substance
so
i i was getting pissed because in my
addiction i couldn't even get high off
heroin
the fentanyl was way more stronger
so
i
that's when i started binging on meth a
lot
because it was just the complete
opposite of a nod
stay up for like
days weeks
at one point i was in psychosis
so i ended up emitting the drugs like
the the meth
but my brain was so [ __ ] up i was
going through psychosis for like two
three more months after i got off the
meth and i was prescribed
just prescribed pills for that
and it was just it was a [ __ ] mess my
mental health was already i've i've had
depression and anxiety i was in mental
hospitals as a teenager for cutting and
stuff and they were always putting me on
pills that i never [ __ ] took i i
always said they didn't [ __ ] work
but um
and i believe that now
it's because my circumstances made me
depressed and anxious being on the
streets hating myself my i feel like my
mom [ __ ] hates me
so
i just
that's why this time around um i'm i'm
not on meds
i feel a lot better i've i learned how
to work through things
i got i got actually clean
um i'm 107 days clean that's when i went
into treatment that was the last time i
did anything went into 30 day program
and continued my treatment
it's different you know this is my first
time in
10 years of addiction being completely
clean off everything not taking any
medications
um
it's a lot of [ __ ] work
uh
i
do a 12-step program i'm an intensive
outpatient i
i i don't know what's working so i don't
want to stop anything because i don't
have another run in me
a lot of my friends kind of just
like they knew me as a drug addict and
they accepted me for that but then when
they saw how bad i was they just
kind of drifted off and never really
told me why
and as somebody who like craves
connection
that [ __ ] always just get like was the
biggest mind [ __ ] to me because i
thought i was a really good friend i was
like my problems aren't
has nothing to do with you why i smoke
and
do all these things
but
you know it's a lot better now
i'm happy
i want to help other women
i
i really want to help like teen sex
workers
i have nothing against sex work
um there's some badass [ __ ] that do
that [ __ ] and they rock it
but
i i know there's girls like me who just
kind of
end up doing it and you get so locked on
that financial security and
feeling like you're never going to make
as much money as you do when you're
selling [ __ ]
and that's just maybe that is the truth
i don't know
but i
i'm my happiest right now making zero
money
working on myself
um working on the art and reading like i
have so many things that i loved doing
as a kid that i just stopped doing so um
you know making [ __ ] clothes
i i want to provide those kind of
opportunities for girls that that are in
my position i care about all addicts but
i feel like
when when you have a background of sex
work it kind of gets
stigmatized i remember hearing somebody
that saw me in treatment they
they ended up saying about me like oh
she's going to end up right back on the
streets she made too much money she's
not going to want to work in treatment
and i just i laughed when i heard that
like
if i cared about money i'd still be
doing that i i want peace of mind
i want to
i want to wake up and not be sick
so i definitely just see myself working
in treatment so that i can just
pass along what i know now with all the
knowledge i do with no judgment
because um
sex workers are [ __ ] amazing the
woman who
who feel like
you know all i need is me
like that's some powerful [ __ ]
um
but i just think that there's so many
better opportunities and when drugs get
wrapped into it i know at least for me
maybe if i was sober i would have been
so uncomfortable in the situation like
all the situations that i have been in
i wouldn't have even
continued doing it as long as i have i
mean nobody wakes up and says i want to
be a sex worker at 15 years old it was a
combination of a sex addiction feeling
like i wasn't wanted
one not even wanting to be home and i
need to provide for myself somehow like
there's always some underlying thing
with these things that we do that we
don't understand why at first
so i know just taking it one day at a
time
trying not to future trip too much
lizzy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in all of this
um
forgiveness
um
forgiving
others for being sick forgiving yourself
for being sick
i just don't see how i'd be able to make
it through this without being able to
forgive myself for all the things i've
done the manipulation i've done against
men so that i could take care of myself
and other people
um
forgiving myself for my like my
childhood self
for not
for just jumping to conclusions that i
wasn't loved
when now i understand like my mom had so
much going on in her life she i could
see why it was hard to deal with me
i just i think that's the most important
thing because
we can't like dread over stuff that's
been happening or
and i don't
because of my addiction i just i
understand that there's so much more
going on than just what meets the eye
so yeah
all right
izzy thank you so much for sharing your
story
thank you for letting me share and i
wish you the best of luck from here
thank you good luck with rehab thank you
you